welcome to this video playing I may know
EG storm geez DOM is this hmm you Jesus
Egypt no this is Saudi Arabia right yeah
Saudi Arabia they don't Saudi Arabia
doesn't have many chess players they're
not even a member of feeder I'm just
only enough okay a 6-bit uncommon okay
so he's just playing some non
theoretical opening the Queens gambit
some should don't be slightly slightly
better for white but it's not the end of
the world oh this is so interesting that
he allows some this opening of the off
the edge file I am I try I try to make
use of that
hmm okay so g5 you're going to go to h5
yeah very ugly
it should be true maybe we should be to
the same 11 good move or if I e-form
maybe five and I don't want that g4 is
not it's not well timed now this is
better so that if I can take and take h5
IE fibers a complete complete massacre
anyway is not developed at all maybe b5
I'm maybe maybe just 95 here time now I
can blend I'm not giving up giving away
g5 okay so is it if I a form before I am
probably I need to play it for and open
open the position yeah Queen H flour
stir the way to go it was a bit
reluctant to play before because of the
rock on the 8th opposed to my king but
this is true but everything else is just
in my favor so what now between g4 in
order to go to h3 yeah it's just it's
just simple chest but it is also i think
effective yeah yeah yeahs cannot be
serious Queen v6 you're not not going to
survive that Knight f6
he needs to play h5 now I think the only
move or HH six maybe which probably also
doesn't help I'm threatening Knight f6
and immediate disaster on age seven
hmm
this is a very relaxed the answer ok
jack ok King h8 the screen h7 mate so
now it's not made here but I can f 95
which threatens mate
mmm 95
yes this is somewhat similar to to to to
those mate studies well you know that
there is some mate but you still need to
find it ok I cannot produce that this is
wrong the threatened screen age seven
mate Knight takes rook takes king of a
Droog f7 mate so if he needs to make
some defensive move no but she doesn't
make Jack a so then I'm meeting check
checkmate hmm yeah I don't think he had
a defense this is just too much okay
rook t4 was very easy ok the computer
says it is hmm plus 12 plus 12 is quite
quite a lot it says age six and then g4m
this is I would have I would have played
problem look some this looks very strong
you cannot take here this is checkmate
and what is black supposed to play now
just attacking this yeah it's it's a
disaster just that there's the just a
disaster in fact i think it was already
a bit badoo we had to to to take on g3
and allow me to to do this here ok night
f8 or something is tougher but the way
it it was played that this is just it's
just a terrible position for that
something like be five assists Issus is
a better defense atty around here we get
to the area where black is just lost i
think it's it's just too much all my
pieces play and he's got bad pieces and
look at this all on him all on light
light square so dark squares are dead
and this is where the mid also came
alright thanks for watching